previously on grave robbers I'm trying
to survive for one hour today if I get
to what like 306 p.m. Pacific that's
right I continue with doom next week at
the same time good know I've played this
game enough that I've got the moustache
okay conserve some ham oh oh don't
charge that up don't track that up
see I don't fit Jesus Oh
what hit me
no oh my god what hit me
I'm sorry Mike that's a bummer my I
ruined I should have kept moving yeah
halo 2 you just had like Call of Duty
recharge Oh
oh yeah sorry
yeah pers joining this one at grenade go
it's like a dog the treat on his nose
long speckles Oh
suck it you look at a health there's two
of them two health bars down Oh six
minutes left you have six minutes left
oh you escaped dirty health up here nice
throw
I thought that got him there you go oh
sweet yes in quit so that was well that
was last week's episode as you can see I
died pretty soon in Doom again for those
who haven't been here the last two weeks
we put permadeath in every single game
so we die in one we move on to the next
we are on halo combat Evolved right
toward the end of the mission halo the
second mission on heroic we decide to
play in heroic so where I would have a
fighting chance to get potentially far
into the game if we did legendary I
would have died already you definitely
would have you got close in a few
moments when those jackals were chased
or those elite rotation yeah those red
ones that's what we were just saying as
I was running is it's gonna be like
either a loose grenade that's gonna go
off or it's gonna be like an energy
sword wielding elite those guys are
persistent they will they will hunt you
down cool might as well jump right into
it here's the list just looking back
there you go so if when rob is if he
dies in halo at all or if he beats it we
will move on to Dark Souls remastered
and I'll be playing that on normal just
because there's not really so I wonder
how long I last in that but I don't have
to worry about that yet maybe not even
on this episode the point of today is
for Rob to get to exactly 307 p.m.
Pacific so he has survived an hour and
halo to continue
sorry halo next week let's get into it
huh word word oh there's that wonderful
wonderful music
so this should this should uh uh uh
resume game yeah they should take off
right so there's the last part of this
mission on a mission on halo we're on
the last of the three different with a
strange groups yeah drops a cliffside
one now right this one little close
quarters potentially yeah perfect all
right yeah whoa yeah yeah that'd be
funny the Banshee killed you God do they
they launched their secondary right I
don't believe they have the bombs in
this oh you're right I think - they have
them huh yeah cuz that's when you can
start using it as well yeah yeah I think
it's a little tricky
all right I'm already getting scared of
this people
these guys suck all right I'm putting a
go yeah there's a bunch of elites around
here friendly family too little slow
here yeah remember it being this bad
last time a lot more people listen
coming in as a talker yeah whether
you're in YouTube or twitch chat we have
chats open I think or GameSpot weird 789
so please don't fill the graphing and
grunt I did like that aspect of to or
like they had like the lore drops of
like the grunt rebellion all that stuff
how they like recruited backstroking
through the air Michael Phelps wasted
you think these aliens would know their
own grenades and how to like train
accordingly yeah would you get off you
yeah all right yeah yeah Civil War in
Halo 2 and you can decide with the
hunters and the yeah that was pretty
time what the hunters and the elites
against the brutes hunters elites oh my
god you get him hunters elites there's
another race the Grande routes the
jackals and the grunts and the drones
are all on the other side most of them
there are some on both sides pretty much
the brunt oh wow the know the birds you
surf the elites though right hey you got
truth and reconciliation after this if
you could survive this mission yeah I
rewatched there's a checkpoint
oh there's health remember that I
rewatched
although that's leave alone all the
cutscenes the blur ones for the
anniversary of halo 2 those are so good
they look very good yet around is that
it dropships coming right there's more
underground unless they already came up
I believe they're right shot him didn't
you remember a gang so deep in
is the stream lagging if it is I'm gonna
do something god I don't want to die
like this maybe that's better hopefully
for you guys it is okay where's this
last guy come on up there maybe or
farther over there oh there you go
Wow nice [ __ ] humblebrag the
Prometheans enemy ruined halo for me I
can maybe understand that I thought the
the Knights were really cool they're
like that one move they had where they -
up real close to you was I was enjoy
that boys got a scare out of me Cole
bond this is on heroic we figured we'd
give Rob a fighting chance to get
through more than in five minutes yeah
you're coming up on truth and
reconciliation mission 3 after that it's
what three dassault in the control room
no sorry sorry silent cartographer is it
really yeah I guess that's my favorite
mission
all right okay oh yeah that's the joke
of sergeant Johnson somehow he didn't
die on the ring
even though yeah if you get the
legendary yeah he's some like why can't
we just be friends or come here
that wigs Tammy remember Corinne penis
by the hour
Oh what if I died dude he's no oh yeah
I'm gonna say they turn on you if you
killing you so I don't see this mission
getting tough until you're on truth and
reconciliation
carefulness is back to normal
where the leads at there's gotta be one
more no pistol
you know those turrets are called shades
try that on oh crap
nice what's your secondary all right
it's a salt rifle not too happy about
that
figured to be one where delete around
remember I was never great at doing that
covertly or whatever Cortana said you
can I want to say you can you can go
around like punch him or maybe I'm
thinking of like another area you just
can like it's like I think it's actually
on assault control room where you go
around just like punch like every go
yeah when they're all sleeping yeah when
you're inside
nice first area clear jump up that clip
for a second hey man I need your support
yeah true I got him No oh yeah weird 789
I was saying all the couples are name is
for supernatural stuff oh really
yeah banshee phantom shade Spectre
Spectre is that are those I believe
those weird things in Halo 2 and the
tunnels that are like transporting
vehicles no I think spectres are the
equivalent to the Warhawk
I think they they're like they're like
oh right yeah yeah there with the turret
on the back and then there's the ghosts
obvious oh great
race what are those things called from
Halo 2 and then you have a phantom drop
ship drop ships later on the series
cooler you have it kind of the first
ones in this game are so weird looking
like a weird no man's sky ship yeah it
wasn't healthy yet today [ __ ]
[Music]
get out there's some dams those kneelers
yeah they kind of snuck up on God see
that was a grunt ha ha it's got to be a
grenade that's gonna do it I think or I
think it's gonna be a grenade or like a
[ __ ] flood with a rocket launcher
do they know yeah yeah that's a good
point yes that that'll happen before you
even realize it if I get there yeah cuz
you gotta get I might get there that's
how it's gonna go like yeah you got to
get the 343 Guilty Spark I don't know go
something like a troll room but those
vehicle sections could be tough yeah I
agree
so I'm a cartographer I don't think so
the needler gets so much better in Halo
2 well you could do a wheel bit too
coven enslaved a lot of different races
I don't think I was just like grunts the
drones
see city who elite oh crap just stood
there he threw his grenade we're just
waiting to see what happened
God neighbors are so messed up like yeah
who thought of that my god the grunts
are coming out with a good needs Jesus
oh that wasn't much nevermind alright
the active camera on the next section
easy you find it right yeah I think it's
the next section bunch of turrets no sir
got some hunters to take down your first
hunters uh underneath the tractor beam
which will be here yet member they come
down from the truth and reconciliation
before you go up and you know the pistol
he's just Bryce you got I don't know I'm
a jumper get yeah we don't talk about do
them anymore
oh there's definitely other leads around
here I remember when Halo 4 came around
you actually kind of had to worry about
ammo a little bit maybe not worry but
the weapons have lower capacities from
what I recall I feel very vulnerable
without my pistol yeah yeah I'll the
only thing you have is long range
yikes Wow a little bit of dodge there oh
god I don't have anything [ __ ] go
start punching yeah oh yeah oh you want
to go okay up ends at ropes they know it
thank God for the fridge
other focus on the dropship good
yeah we're playing halo combat Evolved
for those anybody just joining this is
crave hoppers we we put permadeath in
every game so if Rob dies in halo at all
we move on to Dark Souls remastered if
he doesn't and if he survives an hour
today then we'll play Halo next week
same time like that killed him before
those even exploded Oh
oh yeah oh there's cam over there
there you go that's right it's me boys
daddy's home Oh
yeah I think you knock over the turret
oh damn oh oh gosh it's such a funny
defi Oh Oh God when did they take away
the falling damage hallo - oh no shields
oh I think it's time for Dark Souls
ooh I what that happened so far and I
knew that was gonna have it the second I
will the jumps are floaty you had a lot
of time to see your death coming wait
okay alright here we go
yeah it's probably bring up maybe bring
up a list while loading up the ps4 is
this not connected I really hate it dude
it was falling damage in Far Cry 2
alright I don't have a cord that's
connected to it
it was the case damn it okay yeah you
want to swap oh you're gonna need to
turn it on okay obviously turning on
swap the HDMI there
man for those just joining for those
just joining joining we put permadeath
into every single game so three episodes
ago we started with fire crying I made
it to the end died freakin ate it on a
zipline
I don't know this controller is
connecting mic was playing done cool he
died same episode last 17 minutes there
get the last of us ready uh-oh we got it
ready this morning yeah so yeah Mike
died burnt burned alive oh and then I
just played halo died freakin eight
friggin ate it dude that was not a long
fall either just it was because your
shields were down yeah I was 100 on that
oh damn I'm gonna move this screen a
little bit for my sake of course you
should just okay to clarify if there's a
time I'm trying to think if in Dark
Souls there's a time I need to die I
don't think so that's blood-borne
already 12 minutes 12 minutes all right
man dude we're gonna go through two
games easily possibly three depending on
balletto so yeah we are like skipping
cutscenes when possible for the sake of
we were not doing like a long play but
yeah you'll have to do the intro I don't
want to think about Dark Souls yet
although I got cocky last time and
that's what happened so again until 3:06
I just have to survive til 306 I got the
asylum demon
I played this before last time I played
Dark Souls remastered was kind of when
it came out before e3 mm-hmm game play
down yeah it was it was tuned to halo I
gotta go through the longest terms of
sigh so anyway this is 25 minutes thank
you leo
I appreciate that be a sorcerer that is
a good idea why is that I'm average you
get ranged magic attacks it'd be
conservative well it makes certain parts
easier it makes other parts [ __ ] what am
I gonna I'm more experienced as like a
knight though so I what the [ __ ] sorry
I'm sorry
Oh r2 goes Fester okay sorry
it's another page of this stuff except
there we go I think we can make it to
alien isolation today thanks Ryan ah
alright Witcher 3 a lot of people mmm
wanting that I guess see it exciting
death yeah alright this should all be
good show blood no Seth says I wish you
family and isolation was earlier man
we'll get to it this rate enter name
what should be like our default grave
hoppers name when we come up with one
Daryl
[Music]
route Ralph
ok Ralphie because then we can calm
Ralphie
ok yeah go right to it Ralphie for sure
sure class ok so yeah I do I want to do
a sorcerer I don't or a PI Roman
I'm ight do I think I'll do the either
the warrior the knight health what am I
looking at I'm looking at vitality will
be helpful with night I'll do a night
cuphead Jesus yeah so yeah we're trying
to pick games that we actually have a
decent fighting chance uh what do I want
to finally master key maybe mm-hmm
Resident Evil
where's Evil 4 will be after I guess I'm
just more asking about it because I
don't know like I don't know that game
very well like do you think you'll get
far resi before um yeah I mean I think
so I said that about doom but uh let me
just do a similar face Hank is pretty
good ally oh that guy that Wow
I don't want to make this like a take
too much time to do like a monster
factory thing oh here we go
customize and I'll do similar
yeah that looks like Ralph why am I
getting attached to him he's gonna die
that's fine all right
pray for me except why can't I accept oh
sorry very slim ponytail little slim oh
you'll shoot your eye out Ralphie oh
that's what that's from
can I skip this real all right
ooh that rats probably played this one I
have I'm not a Dark Souls guy I played
blood-borne that's about the souls there
we go oh man
I'm already wait the night's already
over encumbered damn it sugar in the
warrior Oh what was that guy doing
crying I'm not gonna bother
what happened to Halo what happened to
Halo
well I died essentially it was on truth
and reconciliation I was facing off a
grunt and an elite on a stone walkway
bridge and they took off my shields and
then I well I thought I could stick the
landing by jumping and getting away from
fire and I died I saw the image I have
been playing Ghost Recon ghost mode
alright so
anvil one gaming I've been the one
making the list and doing the tiling of
time I've generally just started well I
mean when I estimate right when you
start playing the game so what 308 p.m.
will uh it's not an hour from the begin
of each games the hour from the begin of
the episode yeah so 308 p.m. maybe that
makes sense can I get this quick yeah
that makes sense
all righty whoops that's the okay not
gonna go so the asylum demons through
there when I eventually oh no I do have
to go through they're going some train
remember from Dark Souls I have to know
I could just go to the left here there's
a guy here though
wing zero says any Gears of War game now
no gears war in the list [ __ ] sorry that
was that's the boss oh really i mean you
fight him later you're supposed to but
yes could you fight him now i yeah
technically I'm not going to yeah
similar thing happens at blood-borne you
fight this werewolf okay this guy shoot
at Mike alright
Wow forgot about this guy why do I not
have is the slowest arrow and yeah they
give you a little bit of a and it's
stuck in me though let me quit my talk
about guys like in a nightmare
were you like you know you those
nightmares where you can't punch or it's
like you feel like you're punching
underwater it's like that yeah sick
comparison alright now I got my shield I
feel better
I need a better sword that's not broken
I don't think I'd beat it I don't think
I missed there we go
sweet alright we're in business Robin
Robert sorry you can call me Robin only
fight you can call me Nighthawk
alright am i over encumbered still a
little bit yikes
Wow stab him okay and he got of war we
thought about God of War but decided not
to because of just how story heavy that
game is Arkham games hmm that might be
interesting the most part you'd want to
get god of War's gets pretty slow pace
to something yes why how awesome that
game is it is an awesome game and the
combat is pretty tight I mean I could
maybe see it if we jumped ahead a
significant amount but I don't know I
think there is just too much story like
you what you want to gain that that has
a consistent about a gameplay right
because the Last of Us does at the
beginning but then after that it's kind
of ocean well come on you can skip watch
that here is that was scary
he's our old friend come on yes I'll do
it just sure
go ring the bells I get it nice now I
got my health it's guys lazy got my ace
deuce flasks those heal me as opposed to
blood-borne though it will reef or it
won't
I can't just farm them come on dude I
get it let me uh there we go no I think
that's everything sorry I'm just making
sure in dark souls you kind of want to
talk to everybody as much as possible
all right yeah once I level up I really
got to up my endurance so I'm not over
encumbered as you can see I'm kind of
walking slowly mm-hmm and we're back
here no man's sky permadeath wouldn't be
too bad but I think that game is very
boring to watch yeah it would be all
right
[Music]
GTA could be good [ __ ]
and get out of here yeah GTA open-world
someone mentioned Ghost Recon ghost mode
I've been playing that a lot lately
that is that is perma that's like the
game makes you have permadeath man I'm
coming up against the
do I want to go fight this guy in here
and I got this is this is pretty much
don't say that
do this I'm got it I've done it before I
just still come here come here you son
of a gun Oh what oh yeah come at me oh
all right got my ace this Estus flask
ready there's only one way I got a heal
up all right here we go you got it
yeah wing zero system I mentioned that
earlier it goes mode oh he's my first
test whoa all right got the downward
attack let's do this
sorry yeah god damn it I'm so slow
[ __ ] I'm the warrior come on come on
okay
hell yeah I got him right up his crack
oh he's gonna you're always gonna use oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh it's no problem
come on come down what's done come on
come on come on come on oh that's this
uneven Estes Oh timesplitters is good 15
years ago that game is still dope
timesplitters 2 all-time class oh [ __ ]
yep
get up oh damn it
Rob just for just so you know yes if I
have my shield up and I get hit it'll
drain my endurance first instead of
health gotcha
shields are a little more important in
this game - way more boring than
blood-borne whoo that was a little tense
he had it yeah and now I can like rank
up and stuff get out of the asylum I
kind of remind me of like a no man's sky
animal just because I've known that sky
on the brain just like a jack oh there's
our next game installed or knew what was
coming
hey by the way by the way you're gonna
switch game soon all right now flying to
undead burg her to the sorry yeah
Firelink shrine
all right so that went well yeah you got
think I hit once used one Estus flask
just say congratulations good job
congratulations you've won I really
should go straight to the Blighttown
make this interesting no I'm not gonna
don't die Mike they want to see the list
I'll show you the list again
it's a giant birds coming to pick me up
bring me a Firelink shrine tight this is
where we're at
we're on dark souls this is not up to
date unfortunately I died in halo fall
damage so Last of Us remastered on
grounded mode and then Resident Evil and
an alien isolation which I'll have a
heart attack on scream for Metal Gear
Solid five Zelda breath little wild
games are subject to change
remember that are you doing master mode
for breath well I hear we are going to
fire link it's pretty much the hub of
this game what hardware are we using for
this stream oh the the actual computer
we stream with that's a good question I
actually don't know if I know that but
right now we're on ps4 Pro I'm going all
endurance right there yeah yeah I need
that I'm at dodge I you know I movement
I very much like to have those kind of
builds those characters still pretty
slow if I that's better no not at all
actually
yeah I'm sorry Nathan I died in Halo
that sucked
I really sucked
I'm gonna talk to this guy u-turn
gameplay I have a tiny a little bit I
know I asked you to turn down before but
nicocure today a mai tai supporters -
yes
Thanks did for a cry 5 yeah and I died
got like an hour into it that's the
longest runs no halo as I think it must
be alright cool
I'm gonna go to the undead burg if I get
through undead burg I'll be happy I
think I will
oh wait do I want to try and member I
just played this if I can go down and do
anything yet
man I'm slow I should have picked
warrior cool who feeds that guy so when
I get Estus flasks shards I'd bring it
back to her and she will make my health
potions more potent get away from this
yeah following oh I would I can totally
see falling being my demise in this oh
that guy's got fire bombs above me come
on
I'm gonna kill this guy working back
down for them oh my god I see you guys
saying Dead Rising we'll consider it
Oh Dead Rising would be very fun
actually that's a very very good
what would we swap it for oh my god dude
no this isn't so close to the edge
there's a Ledge under this I don't care
I feel like this getting this show makes
the person who's not playing yeah cuz I
can't you're not in control it's the
equivalent to like a car about to drive
off a cliff when you're riding close no
I was to say when like I don't know I'm
sure everyone that has has had the
experience like when my mom would sit in
shotgun and I would learn to drive she
was just the worst yeah I cannot imagine
you would non-stop fighting those brakes
on the passenger side for rice drivers
school yet okay we'll do Dead Rising but
we're not gonna battle might be art so
like we have nine games but well okay
that's like one season if like you guys
like the show enough and keep watching
it then we'll go past that I'm not gonna
cut away I don't miss anything
yeah there's a rat coming up I'm about
to kill why can't I
yikes okay I could see this speeding oh
damn
nice
that goes toward like town and whatnot
all right here we go a lot of stuff
happening up here is the undead burg I
have as many people have done this
thousands of times throughout my Dark
Souls career yeah with one life though
no [ __ ] so if I was if I wasn't playing
for the show there's a bonfire up here
that you can use to farm Souls mmm kind
of oh don't want the axe instead wings
are careful Mike you'll be on the next
game soon laughs out loud why is he
singing I am now come on come on
Jesus thank God for that wouldn't oh I
got that one got me oh damn dude he did
you see how long he would have kept how
far he would've kept rolling flows of
that post all right
all right here we're coming up to
shaving down here man
ah here we go I really wanted my
endurance higher so I'm dodging faster
and running I don't fight him yet don't
worry dick I know ooh calm down give me
those hot Souls
all right I'm gonna kill this guy he's
annoying [ __ ] few more up their bonfire
I'll get this how many don't have can i
crush some of those soul I see that's
the thing on this show I kind of want to
front load all those these items so
these give you they just give you souls
mm-hmm
normally I would save those but in this
case strengthen endurance sweet hey so
this is how you you can farm here
because they just reach once you light
up once you've the rested upon for
everybody resets that's what's why these
games are kind of smart and how they
make you do the risk reward up should I
rest or not this part can get kind of
slow that's the thing about this game
though it I'll think it's boring and
then all of a sudden I'll be at 2%
health I want to go down here yet I
don't I'm not gonna fight I got the
spear guys these guys gonna be a pain
I'm not careful come on
don't be
what there we go okay in dresses out oh
god oh god no oh alright
I'm not risking that jeez oh sorry I
knew that was there I'm sorry a lot of
this is Muslim oh really
I guess yeah ooh crowd control come into
play I'm sure blood-borne will make it
into the show at some point might as
well if we're doing this light this is
my favorite Souls game wings Eurosystem
blood yeah it's either blood-borne of
this it kind of just depends on which
one I played most recently it's usually
a blood-borne but I love how open unto
this game world is and how it loops back
in on itself blood-borne is a little
more confined still amazing level design
I think blood-borne is level design on a
smaller scale on a smaller scope is
better but this says in terms of the
overall world is great
I like neo a lot too even considering
it's you know like a offshoot from this
genre
I don't think that is better
not at all
okay don't know I want to rest here for
this reset them no I'll go
damn Oh God
endurance running low Maxie oh Jesus
oh god I'm low
Hey look do it there we go okay um I'm
not gonna go mess with a Havel yet when
I get up there there's this dude there's
this like mini-bosses guy that you can
fight up here that I'm not even gonna
attempt to he would destroy me he's
harder later on
why is he harder lair oh sorry
he's totally easier later on there's a
part when you're down by the lake that I
can run into them as well this is not a
fake chest is it so there are fake chest
literally they will sprout teeth and eat
you all right sweet some grenades
okay cool
so for you it was falling damage both
times for me it was fire that's likely
to happen again
it could crazy there are some bosses and
whatnot that would be happy if I buy
that those guys I don't want to fight
yet guys
you ever talk about the halo I I'm just
thinking about how interesting it was
that when hit when they were released
they were about to release halo I think
they did a last-minute change the title
put combat Evolved on it because they
felt halo was like not a very like this
didn't reflect the game at all you know
II mean like like an angel halo you
couldn't explain what halo was right at
that point yeah the game world or oh
[ __ ] is this weird to think Oh God
fall off get off fall off later go easy
like that sorry that's oh I should get
that that could have been something good
I played this game I think that's pretty
clear so far
sweet all right
no lure these guys up and then there's a
boulder that's gonna fall down you dick
he's behind me I forgot to get the guy
the top of the tower to the left now
yeah yeah Oh a spear dude I want to go
up and get that Archer but this dude
will follow me up and pinned me up there
that archers gonna hit me again
knock-knock sneaky sneak me ah sweet all
right someone dropped something didn't
he yeah
don't want to use that that was not
going down there uh no thank you for
watching Isaac come on it says thanks
for the stream gents whoa alright pretty
well I got a boss semicolons fairly well
I mean I okay I might have to go back to
the bonfire before I fight the next boss
to rank up a tiny bit cuz he's up at the
top of this tower yeah I'm gonna do that
there with me
cringes says this game is more relaxing
than halo I don't know I mean I can be
if you're doing alright
but maybe it's cuz it's not first-person
I don't know I'm not relaxed okay
Castro what how much near the boss yeah
it happened I'm uh it's the what do you
want to call it
not the asylum demon he's on top of the
wall and I can do the falling thing on
him oh man I really need endurance for
this part
I mean I don't but I want to be faster
in general I'm not gonna need the shield
yeah well never mind sorry I was dumb
tarus demon yo Taurus demon yeah yo you
get out of my way
Oh oh that was bad
get out get away get away drink it oh
that was the gold I thought those a guy
behind you
okay I'm gonna redo that because I want
wait how many yes oh I didn't light this
bonfire see I'm tempted to Kindle this
bonfire so I can get ten Estus flasks
man damn okay um yeah yeah I need Mike
you do you know I don't think I have
enough yeah I have enough humanity so
I'll get ten Estus flasks instead of
five if I Kindle this
Hansol yeah to reverse although first
which he is humanity there are a lot of
weird RPG systems in this game that I
don't even think it's worth explaining
because I'm not gonna survive crazy long
there we go so now I'll have 10s is fast
instead of five at this bonfire
specifically okay I probably actually no
this is a good bonfire to do that
regardless cuz you come back here a lot
but I also want to beat this boss
all right don't need was he swinging
yeah I have no idea how a warrior waist
cloth mmm it's tempting to lighten my
load a little bit I don't think I would
know we're good
oh no what was that no no I got invaded
well oh no that's such [ __ ] get out
of here that's such [ __ ] I don't
know why that's [ __ ] so because I
kindled I could get invaded and I didn't
consider that but it was orbit sorry not
because I Kindle because I reverse
hollowed damn it no I I didn't think
that was gonna happen I don't think you
thought that was gonna happen
no I didn't turn the game off line but
whatever I brought that on myself
uh-huh all right here you go
Wow flying three games this is not up to
date ladies and gentlemen we are on lots
of us now oh wow what a day it's been
don't count that people are saying no
it's the same person saying it over and
over yeah I was doing well up until then
actually and I'm pretty good against the
Taurus demon oh you did good give us six
more minutes I can do that there's to be
less they don't count it huh no
it's too late now it's too late all
right grounded mode here we go it's
unlikely that I would have gotten past
the taurus demon and yeah catastrophic
says once you pass a taurus demon you
have a lot to contend with if I got to
the [ __ ] gargoyles I would have
gargoyles give me more trouble than they
should
especially when they the second one
comes in halfway through yeah as Eric
green pointed out it was also pretty
humiliating how they kind of boxed me in
so I turned my back on this player that
killed me and fight my way out hack my
way out that way would the fire bombs
falling on me from above like the
whoever joined knew what they were doing
about wanting me in he just stood there
he stood there that's so messed up I'm
excited for this though again we are
gonna skip cutscenes when possible just
for the you know what's gonna be really
goddamn terrifying as if you get to the
subway parts where the clack clickers
are all over the place ya pehle purrs
right death is death we'll go into the
last of us how many times you play this
game I played it once have you done it
wasn't grounding right you know you know
like know what ground emote is I know of
it it's very survival heavy oh yeah it's
not just like more difficult like
smarter enemies it is like the survival
elements you have way less ammo Jake
Decker's in Pittsburgh today seeing
radio had otherwise he'd be excited to
watch this this is his favorite game
well second favorite game after The
Witcher
[Music]
it's games so good yeah you can't lose
in the last of us you didn't play
grounded mode buddy
so what else what like what should I be
expecting in grounded mode use so it
sucks because you want to use melee as
much as possible because you don't get
much ammo but then of course melee you
open yourself up to a clicker just
ripping your face off all right you get
like oh yeah for sure with clickers
mm-hmm even like the humans at some
parts if you have your ammo is pretty
limited to begin with in this game if
you happen to join us expecting to see
halo I've got a little bit of a back
story I can share Rob died in Halo 4
[Music]
from falling damage and then I died in
Dark Souls from a player that invaded me
yeah we gotta get past this intro
he does look younger here gonna die in
this can you probably well I mean
technically Sarah's about to die but
that doesn't count you have oh that
doesn't count I you see him in Iowa
Wyoming later Wyoming in the fall yeah
the one hit melee weapon kill after you
stun an enemy it's pretty good one hit
melee weapon kill yeah you when you stun
an enemy you it gives you an options
like smoke them with a board or shut up
oh right yeah so we're gonna go till 308
but I think we get started once you
actually start the game because this is
technically not really game yeah is the
last of us
Tommy come honey the heat a PG Tommy
okay okay Tommy this is a tea rated game
rate going
no no not you him I'm not driving dude I
don't know
stealth games are gonna be good they
must have left their stove
of course
I got a kid Joe so do we have room keep
driving
later Joe is such a such a hard-ass no I
don't think you're supposed to really
like Joel that much no oh I love the
ending in this game don't talk about it
you don't remember it no I remember it
oh I just I know we're not gonna get
there we're not gonna get to the ending
but I also know that some people in the
Chad have not played it yet Splinter
Cell will be good
hitman will be pretty funny hit me
enough enough
oh oh yeah you're done want a hug
those Hospital patients
oh you're right
you just saw all right we're through oh
damn
that's a good point why isn't he honking
yeah you're about to get shot Oh day
Oh interesting this is yeah this is
where switches huh said Joel yeah
yes this is hallo got him here take this
brick there's a joel and starts licking
the blood off the brick Joel this works
take this brick hallo looks good stop in
at the Wawa Lutz um Tommy Bahama shirts
hey Tommy you got a minute
all right this is a very good opening
yeah it's that's the stage well
[Music]
[Music]
I'll say I think maybe we should wait
till you get to Boston and start
counting down
I'm psyched I hear
go
I think that's unlock what I was gonna
say I forget
so that would unlock Alya I'm a little
nervous right now the ophiocordyceps
virus don't be dramatic Tommy
yeah this is Texas where all the guns
semester
[Music]
well you're gonna have weapons in the
city in Texas you probably get this
shootin die again yeah
Boston how many years later 20 it's a
while right is it 20 years 15 it's fine
maybe I'm over remember hearing that
like vegetation growing through cracks
and like you know basically a
post-apocalyptic city like this it would
happen in like five years you start
seeing this is what I remember hearing
like vegetation taking over like I know
you're in your 50s in this game Joel is
yes
oh we're skipping scenes in grave
hoppers nine-inch colas where we're
playing the games we don't want to do
long place for this specific show we
skip scenes play on the harder
difficulties it is 20 lots of someone
saying but it could be wrong where am i
where am I in Texas still Boston but now
I'm in Boston yeah are you always in
Boston you know you go across the whole
country
alright Boston we end up in Pittsburgh
Wyoming Colorado Salt Lake City San
Diego maybe at the end I know Salt Lake
City
yeah a lot of world-building going on
but
so I keep going yeah these guys are
gonna be jerks
put your business you got the day off
busy friend firefight
[Music]
l1 damn I forgot it was weird like that
yeah because the point of this the point
of this show is not to play through the
whole game it's just to keep the action
going and see how long we could survive
we're trying to beat the game and we
don't wanna waste time in the episode
watching cutscenes all the cutscenes are
on YouTube if you feel like watching
those though should we start we'll start
when you it's clear I just
you - yes she's been asking around
trying to find it Marlene
what are the fireflies robber
remember the last of us to part 2
trailer it was you see the Firefly logo
on that sign right that's how people
news last of us mm-hmm it's always cool
and that happens in trailers are like
reveal trailers like it III and stuff
yeah like the one I was watching what
reason anyways it was the God of War
remake sorry the God of War with Corey
bara log playing yeah I remember that
it's the second like Kratos steps out of
the shadow and ever we're just goes all
oh yeah that's pretty cool how do you
think it's going look at my arm that's
it secret tunnel wow this is Wow no one
could ever notice this those books
really those books there is empty wine
bottle it's foolproof that's a fairly
long drop he's a very long drop
yay do
let's grab our gear mm-hmm wanted a
secret tunnel let me think about a
secret tunnel out of the office back to
my apartment yeah that'd be great tight
boss fair yikes
it's uh pube sweet when should we start
timing this maybe when you get out of
the tunnel you do now okay um
you've got like eight minutes from when
we start timing it pretty much maybe
well they're probably gonna be a natural
spot where we come on okay you come on
oh man the part where you get toward
bill that'll be pretty scary the booby
trap to town once again very good job
hiding the secret tunnel
be careful what am I not a trick
question
wishing Eagle was responsible for their
death every king should you can you die
from fall damage in the last of us if so
rob will find a way
I guess we could start timeing from now
so you got till 326 our first enemy
encounter maybe trying to think cuz you
fight bandits I believe save bandit
alright
good eye good eye
whoops
after you he's first lady you must be
thinking of someone else it's all really
dude
this way
down through here
Robert still got our guns he better once
we get our merchandise back it should be
easy to unload
speaking of merchandise when's that next
shipment dude hold up there guys in this
area yeah then you got nolan north later
to plays david does it was Billy bill
okay yeah be careful this halo is very
very far away from us right now Oh Oh
you choose to come right all right cool
quick quick damn dude I gotta go as soon
as you almost all right so how about
from that gunshot we can start counting
okay every twenty eight cuz you killed
someone you barely aim usually a [ __ ]
marine dr. Zhivago
don't leave it to do [ __ ] right off Joel
this isn't funny anywhere I like don't
really know the controls that well for
this game odd triangle is melee and
contextual pretty much I think there
square it wasn't doing I was waiting for
a prompt
[Laughter]
I played the game I don't know the
controls that well oh no all right oh my
god oh my god okay let's just call it an
episode calling what are we on next up
Rosie before nice suite I promise I will
get far in resin before that's a promise
test didn't do [ __ ] that was the third
episode of grave hoppers here we go
we're going on - Wow we really now I was
waiting for a prompt I was waiting for a
prompt honest to God I could tell man
yeah sweet okay cool
you're almost done clipping the final
death thank you
sweet resi will for next episode a week
from today what is that
34 August 2nd or something that was
three games today yep yeah but yes as
people have mentioned this the first
time falling damage didn't get you yeah
so how long was that technically if you
started from the gunshot that was
probably what 2 minutes if that yeah
great alright well that's gonna do it
sweet thank you so much everybody for
joining we will be back next week
Thursday 2 p.m. Pacific
we're resonable 4 I'll be playing I
promise I'll get far but we'll be
playing resin you before and we'll see
you then we'll see you then have a great
rest of the week great weekend fish
Bader
[Music]